I don't think Methos any conservative in
America that's been more outspoken of
against the Republican leadership for
the last 14 15 years in myself hi my
name is Matt Welch I'm the editor in
chief of Reason magazine and I'm joined
here today by Richard Vickery the
godfather of political direct mail
especially on for a GOP and conservative
causes thanks for joining us here
I tell us how the direct mail industry
has been affected especially on the
conservative side of the aisle by the
advent of President Barack Obama meant
in the last eight years it's been tough
because whenever a year on people are
perceived to be in power conservatives
were not in power obviously but they a
lot of public felt that they were or if
even if they weren't really bad things
wouldn't happen in terms of the
president would veto the legislation etc
but since Obama has moved into the White
House most conservatives organizations
that we are involved with in our direct
marketing agency have seen significant
increases in returns I have the attitude
that if you're running a conservative
organization of any kind whether it's a
publication a book club a nonprofit that
you should maybe double the size of your
organization this year if you don't
significantly increase the size of your
organization you maybe you should
consider stepping aside and let someone
else run your case there's an enormous
opportunity to greatly grow the
conservative right of center free market
libertarian causes unfortunately what's
bad for America is good to build the
movement to cause do you see that that
cause is being joined by sort of new
entrants younger people coming into the
sort of conservative movement yes
definitely I am second generation mint
and when I came to New York his
executive secretary young Americans of
freedom in the early sixties
not only was i reading the classics but
I know knew many of those who had
written the classics Russell Kirk Bill
Buckley Frank Myer James Burnham and
others and unfortunately today's
conservatives there's a far more of them
and maybe fourth generation we're
dealing with now but they're they don't
know who they are they've not read the
classics they're not as well-informed in
my opinion as they should be and also
something else they're not entrepreneurs
they're not starting new organizations
the second generation started many of
the organization fact probably most
organizations today right of Center was
started by the second generation
conservatives Cato reason heritage the
religious right organizations and so I
would hope that these young people
coming into the movement now would you
know start new organizations we need
thousands of them let let a thousand new
organizations bloom in my opinion isn't
that you know lack of kind of
intellectual underpinning a sort of an
expression of the fact that politics
ultimately is more about culture than it
is about ideas people are attracted to
it because they hate somebody or they
broadly identify with somebody more that
they actually think about the ideas
behind it and isn't that indeed part of
the reason why you know conservatism
lost its way became attracted to to
either figures that they liked or
especially figures that they hated and
they stopped giving that kind of
intellectual no question Matt I think
that too much of today's politics is
personality driven I really enjoy like
I'm glad the conservative talk show
hosts are there and those that right the
popular books but it's to me like a
someone who wants to be a religious
leader and all they do is watch
television and they never read the Bible
they've never read san agustin Aquinas
etc and so there's too much personality
driven
you know aspect of our politics today
and I would hope that the young people
would realize they need to go back to
the roots and and know who they are if
you don't know who you are if you're not
grounded the wind blows this way you can
go that way and the different changes
direction you'll be easily swayed if you
don't know who you are if you're not
well grounded you've been spending a lot
of time with libertarian organizations
and even gave the keynote speech right
at the libertarian party convention in
2008 what's all this flirtation with non
Republican parties man I consider myself
a disciple of Frank Meyer Frank Meyer
was a brilliant conservative
anti-communist intellectual in the 50s
60s early 70s a founding editor of
National Review and Frank talked and
wrote extensively about fusion ISM I've
looked long and hard and I just cannot
find more than a handful of people who
agree with me on everything you know and
so if the cause of freedom has any
future it's going to have that future
because people who more or less agree
are going to come together and I
certainly have a lot more in common with
libertarians and I do people on the Left
which I have almost nothing in common
with ideologically politically and so
I'm just a very much a fusionist I
believe that there's not 51% that agree
with the libertarians there's not 51% to
agree with the social right with the
foreign policy conservatives traditional
conservatives which I consider myself to
be one of so I think we're all going to
have to work together and agree to
disagree on a few issues but we've got
to come together if the cause of freedom
has any future but then again the cause
of freedom or at least the cause of non
democratic party nasai someone who
expanded the government at a higher rate
since Lyndon Johnson expanded regulation
since more since anyone since Richard
Nixon do you understand why libertarians
feel out of place among helpless lutely
I don't think Methos any conservative in
America that's been more outspoken of
against the Republican leadership for
the last 14 15 years and myself wrote a
book called conservative
betrayed how george w bush are the big
government republicans hijacked the
conservative cost i have been very much
persona non grata with george bush and
and his white house Karl Rove Tom DeLay
etc no I'm been very outspoken
disillusioned as libertarians are but if
we are going to go forward and those who
love liberty and freedom are going to
govern America and by the way it's not
going to happen in the next couple years
we didn't get in this mess over and I'm
gonna not gonna get out overnight it's
gonna take six eight ten years at least
we can do that but we're going to have
to do it together quite frankly as
Benjamin Franklin said uh hang together
we're going to hang separately on that's
a note of togetherness we'll have to cut
it off there for recent TV with Richard
vigor II I'm Matt Welch